i could see that hey
theo we saw you in august in atlanta
brandon we were supposed to see you in
march for my birthday but
that obviously didn't happen i was
originally gonna send this video
um because you guys were talking about
oj and his money
and i was gonna tell you that uh years
ago
he set up what's called a rabbi trust
and he gets about 25
000 a month from it and nobody including
the goldmans can touch that money
uh but i figured while i was at it i
would give you a little sink my ink
um i got this in someone's basement
it was supposed to be a winking hello
kitty
and i'm 35 and now it's just a huge
embarrassment yeah the hello kitty looks
drunk dang she kind of reminds me of
maggie q
yeah she does maggie q the half asian
half white girl that you like in that
scary movie oh i love her
yeah now man or woman here nick do you
think i think this is a woman
that's a lady she's a very nice trying
to see where you're at you know nick
yeah we just want to start to gauge you
we're going to eat we're going to ease
you in easily
yeah that was that was a toss-up wow
but if you are a man pretending to be a
woman and looking to dupe some young men
apparently
wisconsin is the state together
um she does look like you're good
beautiful young lady
i mean she's gorgeous too bad she has a
family and stuff you know
white husband and kids oh she does huh i
don't know i'm just guessing and just
yeah
probably though she's shooting him yeah
um she looks like who maggie young the
girl on the left
that's the actress on the left she's in
some scary movies
oh oh super attractive um both of them
are
but that's instrument uh oj i wonder how
he was able to get that rabbi trust
rabbi trump some attorneys he said he
can't take the money yeah some attorney
said it
i was always wondering how he's always
golfing all the [ __ ] time he gets how
much a month
25 grand a month would you guys have him
as a guest on t
fatca i would yup would you
i think so we talked to uh amanda knox
yeah both killed people was amanda knox
uh she was a killer killer
murder nice girl yeah sure
and she's not really a killer either i
mean i don't think she did it she is but
you know the header on the show so she's
like a wren fair she does like
renaissance fairs
oh okay look at see that what
he's into it do you know what amanda
knox is no do you renaissance fairs oh
yes
[Laughter]
unbelievable dude oh
do you know barstool sports dave portnoy
it's so weird the stuff he knows yeah i
don't make chappelle chappelle though
you know
that's why that's why you love them man
yep that's amanda right there
uh and she's rent uh
getting in some ren fair attire oh okay
that's what she likes to do
um that big ass turkey leg oh yeah now
here's a bunch of documentaries on her
you can look her up dude
but now here's the thing that i don't or
you can just watch an episode of this
past
episode 225 look how excited i was i
know right
i was fired up they fell in love oh they
did
oh yeah she has a husband now oh she has
a husband
it might not be a true marriage i don't
know yeah it could be untrue i mean it
was
yeah i don't know where i'm sure i'm
sure she can figure out how to get out
of that yeah
is